Je ne comprends pas comment on a pu appeler des fruits de mer, "des fruits de mer"
Si il y a bien un truc qui ne ressemble pas à un fruit c'est ça
il y a quand même un mec qui s'est dit " ah on dirait un peu une poire, c'est vrai.. dans les"
la couleur ...."  Non.
Je crois que j'ai un petit problème avec la nourriture, je ne sais pas m'alimenter
ben déjà j'ai toujours le dilemme entre "est ce que je commande ou est ce que je me fais à manger?"
un dilemme plutot vite réglé en général
ok pizza
c'est la vaisselle qui est là depuis 2008
j'ai toujours l'espoir au fond de moi que... un jour.....
oh mon dieu, elle s'est lavée toute seule
ceci est totalement impossible
la vaisselle ne se lave pas toute seule
mais on peut toujours rêver
c'est trop génial, pour fêter ça, PIZZA
j'ai aussi du mal à jeter la nourriture
je ne sais pas pourquoi
je garde des vieux plats complètement pourris dans mon frigo
ils ont commencé à muter
c'est super flippant
Cyprien, bonjour c'est le plat de lasagnes blblblblbl
ah quand même
mais le pire dans les trucs qui se périment
c'est le lait
est ce que vous avez déjà bu, est ce que vous avez déjà goûté du lait périmé
c'est juste le truc le plus dégueulasse
sur la planète terre
c'est simple, j'ose même plus gouter le lait
pour savoir si il est bon ou pas
alors j'ai trouvé une petite technique
ah salut chérie tu veux du lait?
Tiens
" chute d'un corps au sol"
okay il est pas bon
alors si je ne fais que commander à bouffer c'est aussi parce que
ben car je ne suis pas doué en cuisine
tout simplement, c'est même pire que pas doué
je suis quand meme le seul homme qui peut louper des pâtes
de l'eau, c'est vrai
merde de l'eau
encore plus fort je suis meme capable de louper des plats au micro onde
elle est où ma fourchette ?
ah oui je l'ai laissée dans le micro-onde
n'hésitez pas à partager ma vidéo sur facebook
et à rejoindre ma page
et allez sur cyprien.fr pour regarder toutes mes autres vidéos
et je vous offre une pizza
Sympa
je crois que je déteste cette personne qui fait des travaux au dessus
je crois que j'en suis sûr